we have the story from Real Clear
investigations it's been covered quite a
bit over the past few months this one is
investigative issues independent
journalist receives January 6 grand jury
subpoena Steve Baker says he believes
actors in the Department of Justice seek
to silence him this is back in August
since then you've received notice that
they actually are intending to
criminally charge you and you are a
journalist you uh uh you work for the
blaze or you're a contributor no I I am
now a full-time investigative journalist
for the blaze I officially shut down my
bands and my operations musically and I
am so you you were acting as a
journalist on January 6 correct you are
friends with uh uh many prominent
journalists notably uh Richie mcginness
yes who was uh uh what did he say to you
that it would be insane if they went
after you for working journalism on
January 6 but now they're coming after
you so what's happening well they
actually made the first threat against
me all the way back in November of 21 I
did my my FBI interview in July of 21 so
6 months after January 6th and then or
actually no that was when they first
contacted my attorney and then we did
the interview in October of 2011 on
November 17th of 21 my attorney got an
email from a assistant us attorney out
of Philadelphia who said your client
that would be me is going to be charged
within the week and that within the week
that was in 2021 yes that would have
been that would have been Thanksgiving
week of 21 that they originally
threatened me with charges we went on a
media press offensive instantly you know
press release started doing you know
podcasts and TV and radio interviews and
things of that nature and so I that
among other things we think they backed
off they were like you know this guy's
too big of a pain in the butt for us to
deal with so they just moved me to the
bottom of her pile the the assistant us
attorney and and so we didn't hear from
them for 20 months they went away now
for 20 months though I kept waiting for
those red dots in my bedroom window
every morning at 6:00 I I I have people
think I'm joking when I say this I don't
have to set an alarm anymore 6:00 every
morning I wake up and I look for the red
dots in my window what do you mean red
dots the the SWAT red lasers being
weapons pointed yeah yeah of course
that's not you know they don't actually
use red dots anymore it's because it
would be at 2: in the morning that's
what I understand yeah yeah yeah but but
it's it's it's what I it's it's what I
expect or what I'm fearful of and and
I've had that burden in my gut for that
long and so uh 20 months went by and
then in August as you can see from that
uh the date on that article right there
by Joe hanaman that in August I got
another call for my attorney said okay
and now we have a uh grand jury subpoena
for you and now subpoenaing subpoenaing
your work from January 6 so they wanted
my videos which was completely uh
unnecessary because we not only offered
that to them during my FBI interview you
know free of charge so to speak with as
a yes a compliment uh service to the FBI
but more importantly it was part of the
cooperation and then secondarily we
offered it to them yet again uh to the
the uh uh Department of Justice through
exchange with my my attorney there's
nothing to hide there it it didn't
matter I I don't think I was going to I
was going to cause anybody that was
there on January 6 any harm because they
were already on a thousand other videos
anyway so it it really wasn't going to
hurt anybody if I gave them my videos so
that my thinking anyway at the time so
we get a grand jury subpoena the problem
with a grand jury subpoena is that they
don't Grand jurries are not seated for
misdemeanor
charges only for felonies it's like okay
crap what are they looking at what are
they going to try to do now what have
they been scheming and concocting for 20
months while they've been silent so we
we complied I I gave them a flash drive
actually I actually confronted my FBI
agent in the parking lot at his field
office with my attorney standing beside
me and I G real him for about 15 minutes
about what were what they were doing for
20 months you know what's going on I
don't know I don't know I said no that's
BS you do know because you're the one
that actually has to write the statement
of facts based upon which the Department
of Justice will then file charges
against me so it's going to be your
recommendations you know and he wouldn't
tell me and so uh another five months
goes by I'm actually sitting in Thomas
massie's office in DC rer building and I
get another text from my attorney and
it's like you know cuz when your
attorney CS you it's never good and so I
step out into the
hallway and uh he says okay I guess this
is the big day this was on Thursday
December 14th and he said uh they are
asking you to selfs surrender in Raleigh
North Carolina uh on Tuesday so this
been the Tuesday Before Christmas week
of this past year so I uh I took my my
big breath I uh walked
outside and then I tweeted out that it's
happening and within 20 2 4 hours you
know I had 4 and a half million views of
that tweet and then the blaze went into
high gear and there were other media
appearances as well over the next 24
hours within 30 hours by 5:00 close of
business on Friday the 15th of December
my attorney gets another call from the
FBI agent and he says okay we're going
to postpone your selfs surrender until
after Christmas wow all right so now so
my other my lead attorney CU I have six
attorneys on this case now and so my
lead attorney then he takes over so he
contacts the new assistant us attorney
because now they' they've assigned me to
somebody else during that 30h hour
period they took it away from uh
assistant us attorney Anita Eve out of
Philadelphia and they assigned it to a
guy by the name of Adam Dreer out of DC
so got a new guy Young Gun on the case
and and I guess that's the that's the
kill shot you know the guy he's he's the
he's the specialist right so um the week
between Christmas and January 1st my
lead attorney got on the phone with him
said okay what's what's going on here
okay what right now what he says is that
they're going to delay the selfs
surrender till sometime mid January and
because we know Mr Baker's travel
schedule and what he's doing because I
stay on the road almost fulltime and he
says uh we'll give you seven give him
seven to 10 days notice before he needs
to come in and present himself oh uh
okay okay I'll pass that along to my
Cent uh what are the Charges going to be
well um I can't tell you what what do
you mean you can't tell well I could
tell you but we're not because as soon
as I tell you Mr Baker will tweet it
out as is your right though yeah as is
my right now technically he could fall
back on the fact that until an actual
judge or magistrate signs the arrest
warrant there are no charges so you know
well so it's the end of January what's
the what's the latest that's it oh we
haven't heard from them
since wow I think I think this shows uh
you know you look at the Trump egene
Carroll case
and there's there's no justice system it
is weaponization of it's remarkable to
me Trump gets Accused by some some
crackpot old woman of a story that's
based off of that that bears striking
striking resemblance to Law and Order
SVU denies it and the denial is
defamation yeah then he he he gets he
gets accused of fraud in New York the J
issues a summary judgment without
hearing any evidence and says don't
doesn't matter Trump did it now in the
trial to determine the the amount of
Damages and whether or not he falsified
business records all the witnesses are
like oh no Trump was doing business on
the level it's totally fine doesn't
matter we've already said so what we
have here I think it's just it's proof
of they will do whatever they can get
away with and with you you're on the
line you're not some you know you're not
Ben Shapiro no you don't have millions
of followers but you're not nobody
you've got you work in media and a lot
of people are paying attention to your
story if you were like so many of the
other J Sixers who bumbled about
confused like I'm not talking about the
riers I'm talking about the woman I met
who said she showed up an hour after the
riot doors were open there were no
barricades and she walked around
confused and went home 18 months
sentence yeah she does not have the
platform you have as a journalist and so
now you've put them in this position
where they're like we got to get him but
oh man he's too loud this last Thursday
myself and four of my attorneys in
Dallas in De Plaza we did a press
conference interesting yeah Cho location
chosen you stand on the little box in
the middle of the street well we I made
sure I took uh photos of the X in the
street but the point being is is that we
did a press conference there and I
actually addressed the point that you
were making right there and I said that
exact thing unfortunately there were so
many that had come before me already and
I'm talking specifically about other
independent journalists who have been
jacked up by the system and they did not
have the coverage of me they didn't have
for you know um great attorney standing
behind them they didn't have the power
of the bullhorn of the blaze behind them
at the time and they didn't have the
reach so they they were uh completely
overwhelmed by that most of them having
to uh use um a point Tri you know court
appointed lawyers to defend them that
were probably of a leftist bent to begin
with didn't really care about their case
I know of individuals that have been
jammed into what they call um a uh you
know these these stipulated bench trials
they don't even know what you know the
the the client doesn't even know what
that is what what is that and they try
to explain to them it's a lot simpler
it's easier it's it's going to cost you
a lot less money well basically you're
just walking in and pleading guilty
without the opportunity to present your
case or present any exculpatory or
diminishing you know something that
might diminish your charges or you
diminish your um your sentencing that
sort of thing but specifically to the
independent journalists that have been
caught up in this thing I've watched
trials uh this is a this is a great
example uh a young guy Steven horn also
from Raleigh North Carolina we never
knew each other before the January 6 um
thing but what ended up happening to him
is this this he was 22 years old on
January 6 but he had had a history of
doing journalism since he was 16
including acquiring applying for and
acquiring press passes for various
events that he had covered so when he
goes up to cover that event he actually
tried to acquire a pass he actually
contacted Metropolitan PD um they
wouldn't issue him one he went anyway he
had been covering riots and you know the
20 riots and and Raleigh so he installed
inside of his bicycle helmet a hidden
camera so he didn't look like press he
didn't wear press anywhere and so that
he could blend into the crowd so he gets
uh he he gets arrested Ed he gets the
four basic misdemeanor charges he
decides he's going to do a a jury trial
right so in the process of doing in
putting all this in DC yeah I mean Brave
kid he's he's going and and I'll tell
you exactly why he decided to do that
there's another reporter by the name of
Luke moglen who submitted his story to
the New Yorker he captured the famous
video of the qanan shaman inside the
Senate chamber you know chanting praying
all of that so Luke and um uh uh another
uh journalist by the name of JD Rivera
from Pensacola they basically paralleled
each other through the building took the
same thing JD ended up getting eight
months in prison wow uh Luke of course
didn't because when Luke submitted his
story to the New Yorker the title of his
story was among the
insurrectionists so he had to get out of
jail free card already you know yep he
said Insurrection right right so but
back to Steven horn so step horn says
well look I'm going to you know I'm
going to go declare my innocence in
front of a jury and so they file a
motion for Selective prosecution in his
case his his attorneys do and the judge
a trump appointed judge by the name of
Kelly he would not allow the jury to see
those press badges what what that's
correct how do they how
because yeah wow this disgusting he
might tweet it out disgusting so he
would not allow that jury to see these
now I I went up to DC to cover that
trial I was there for every minute of
that of Steven Horn's trial and so I I
finally reached a level of frustration
one day and you know I I I I ran out
into the hallway to where the the the
attorney's room was and knocked on the
door and then one of them answer the
door and I said you have to present blah
blah blah blah blah and he said we can't
what do you mean you what do you mean
you can't it's the truth about his life
about his career about his desire since
he was a kid to be a journalist we can't
talk about it we're under orders we
can't bring that up and so what they did
is the US attorneys denigrated that kid
they absolutely
completely um made any insinuation that
he was there for any other reason other
than to participate in the riot uh it
was it was completely slammed and they
could not just even show that jury but
you know these were the Press badges he
acquired since he was 16 how what did he
get uh this was a miracle his sentencing
was the day after Reep s sentencing and
that Reep sentencing sent shock waves
through course got chills hearing that
yes wow because he got off so easy with
the slap the wow so so horn only got a
year probation and a $2,000 fine still
too much still too much and if it had
been before EPS very likely it would
jail because because and now before EPS
was the guy I mentioned from Pensacola
JD Rivera he was actually the first
person from the panhandle of Florida to
be caught up in the drag net uh early
January of of uh 21 and he was the first
one arrested in that part of the country
and he was actually contracted by a
television station from mobile he shows
up at he shows up at January um uh 6
with his big gear his big expensive you
know shoulder mounted camera and he's
going through there and going through
and and he went through the same broken
window that Luke mgls New Yorker
submitted his story to they both went
through the same Broken Window Luke mgon
had his iPhone Luke mogelson said yes I
used my phone as a reporter's notebook
and and JD had his expensive gear so
when he gets home and the and the the
the station is all excited when they're
Drive he's driving home on the sth
they're calling you you got all this you
got all this footage it's incredible we
can't wait to see it can't wait to get
it and then when he gets home he doesn't
hear from them at all
a few days later over 20 agents show up
at his doorstep red dots on his wife his
kids family you know what JD's crime was
he never chanted he never said USA USA
he never uh you know sto the steel or or
any chant whatsoever he wasn't wearing
all the Trump paraphernalia that sort of
thing his crime is he had been and had
covered and had been active in the
Hispanic or Latinos for Trump movement
prior to that wow so he gets he goes to
a bench trial so he was smart enough not
to you know to risk a jury but the judge
in his case convicted him and when he
was sentenced he was given eight months
in prison he spent his first two months
in solitary confinement when he gets out
of solitary and he gets into the general
population of this medium security
prison in Georgia the other prisoners uh
thought he was a you know he was some
sort of spy or planter or whatever
because his story fake it had to be fake
because because misdemeanor defendants
are not sent to this prison so they're
all looking at him like going no hey
we're the pros this is what we do for a
living we go to prison we commit real
crimes misdemeanor defendants do not
come to this prison he said no this is
so infuriating thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time